why do this or why do that why dress
like this or dress like that why do
women have to cover in a certain way and
men don't have to cover in the same way
you know it's let's understand the
fundamental issue here
the real problem is who are you going to
follow are you going to follow the
creator of everything or you're going to
follow created beings and their
subjective opinions and ideas
which are ever changing one of the
underlying philosophical
ideas is is of equality from a sort of
liberal sense
of the word and equal opportunities and
equal you know
uh outcome for both men and women um so
it's almost like the world we live in
today doesn't want to recognize anymore
so fundamental differences between men
and women
not to say that one is better than the
other that's not what we're saying
but that there are differences they
don't want to recognize because
you know especially this whole feminist
movement it's it's all about
you know being equal across the board
and they don't really define that and
they don't really look at the
implications of what they're saying
either
sometimes you know so it's um
it's it's definitely men are shamed for
certain things and women too are
shameful certain things you know so it's
uh and this is the thing again when
you're when your information
and your way of looking at the world is
coming from the human mind
a subjective perspective on what you
think is right
given the time you're you live in in
history
you're gonna have problems because it
all boils down to human subjectivity
you know as opposed to when you're
referring to allah the creator of men
and women
you know and therefore he is the source
that's going to be able to tell us the
differences
you know and and tell us the qualities
and tell us how
they can work with each other to to to
benefit themselves and benefit
society
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
first and foremost the prophet salallahu
he said that
basically when a group of companions
came to him and asked you know we're
dealing with these horrible
doubts you know these doubts that if we
believe them they would lead to
horrible doubts and the process he said
that this is good news
this is good news and obviously it's
very it sounds
upsy moronic how is you know big doubts
in faith
good news in the process of he said it's
a sign of high iman think about it
if you have catastrophic life-changing
doubts
about your religion it can't be anything
other than a sign that you have
high faith because you don't wake up in
the morning
and become worried that unicorns don't
exist
because you never believed in unicorns
in the first place so the fact that
these
doubts are worrying you is a sign that
you have high iman
that you actually believe in islam
welcome back to the real estate podcast
in the dunya the three muslims
today we're joined with a very special
guest brother imran hussain
so the first place that i found you was
in an air video
it was an interview with uh uh i think
it was musan
right and you were talking a little bit
about you know you being a born muslim
but having kind of like a pseudo revert
experience right and i can relate in the
same way i was also born muslim
but i didn't really come on dean until a
little later in my life
so tell me a little bit about how that
shaped your life right now
yeah it's you know it's loads of people
find themselves
in this position you know this uh we're
born into muslim families yet because
for whatever reason we tend to sort of
stray away
leave islam to different degrees some
people more so some people may still
call themselves muslim
and still may associate with islam but
not practice
others may completely leave islam
so me personally it was more of
you know looking back i would consider
that i was
for many years not a muslim
because i didn't know anything about
islam i wasn't interested in islam
um you know when it came to the question
of god
it wasn't even that does god exist for
me it was just i had no interest
in finding the answer to that question
um and
you know i was you can say that i was
living like any other
sort of secular atheist at that point um
busy with life trying to do whatever you
know everyone else is doing
um trying to hit those goals that
everyone has these days as far as
worldly goals are concerned
and then you know i got to a point in my
life where i had to really reconsider
you know
life and reality and really think about
these things on a deeper level because
you know everyone gets to the point
where they think sit down and have that
moment where you know is this all it's
about
just this material progress you know
having as much of the world as you can
so i got to that point and then just
went on this search
which led me back to islam
so looking back what was one of the most
important things if you had to pick one
that helped you get that belief in allah
back
one thing um okay so me personally
it was never a sort of rational inquiry
so it wasn't that okay what's the proofs
for god um you know let me weigh them
out and then decide whether god exists
or not
for me instead it's it was more to do
with meaning
you know the meaning and purpose of life
because
from the way it happened for me was i
got to maybe my sort of
mid-teens and i was like okay what's it
all about
you know what's life all about why am i
here because it's really interesting bro
as human beings we we have this tendency
to ask the why question you know with
kids you see it with children as well
very quickly when they're like four or
five years old they start asking why
about everything and anything you know
why this why that so we have this
tendency this
if it's a gift that you know we have
such developed rational faculties
um but what happens is that that why
question at some point in everyone's
life turns in on oneself
you know so you start to ask at some
point why do i exist
you know why why am i here why why why
all this why
experience this life you know what's it
all about so when i got to that point
i i had to find an answer because that
question bro is it's it's very troubling
to the human being you know if you when
you really start considering what you're
what the purpose of your existence is
you can't really focus on anything else
you know everything else loses its
flavor it loses its color
you know all of the things that you were
enjoying two days ago
you know partying with friends you know
going out going to work
you know whatever whatever else we do it
just loses
loses meaning everything loses meaning
until you find the answers to that
fundamental question
so i it wasn't by choice i had to find
the answer so i i started looking in
different places and then
what what really did it for me was when
i came back to
looking into the quran and looking into
islam what i noticed was that islam
provides
a comprehensive picture in regards to
life and what it's all about you know
and and why we're here why we exist
where we're going
and all of these answers are there and
you will find answers in different
philosophies and and
worldviews and ideologies you know you
may find some answers here and there
but the one thing you know is the more
you look into these ideologies they
don't
there's no sort of uh synergy between
them
you know one thing will make sense and
another thing will contradict it or
something else may contradict that
but islam comprehensively addresses all
aspects of
life and it's all puts all the pieces of
the puzzle together so for me that was
what really did it
um you know that sort of practical um
aspect of islam where it actually does
answer all of the questions
it has structured structure and that's
something i noticed too man is uh
i i was into like the new age stuff then
i got into
uh christianity and it just
they had pieces of it but they liked the
structure it liked
the what you said like bringing
everything together
for the complete picture like islam this
or a humdullah bro
yeah and it's interesting that's what a
lot of people like if you
because we work with a lot of uh
brothers and sisters in
in the uk as well and one thing you know
is for many of them it's not really
about oh look i came across a rational
argument for god's existence
you know it's it's deeper than that it's
it makes sense
it fits all the pieces fit together you
know it's comprehensive
like this like you said the structures
panel so yeah that was that was what it
was bro it was just
it answered those questions okay
that being said mashallah yeah that
being said any any brother or sister
right now watching
that's kind of suffering because they're
identifying with an ism whether it be
feminism or liberalism or whatever
what would you what advice would you
have to them to kind of deconstruct from
that
i would tell them to see the thing is a
lot of
people today especially the youth they
ascribe to or identify themselves with
different ideologies without actually
really looking into those ideologies
and what the implications are do they
make sense are they are they coherent
um and they don't do that so it's if
they were to sit out so that's what the
first thing i'll do is recommend them to
really look into whatever they're
ascribing to
and really study it like does it make
sense is it comprehensive you know are
there any contradictions internal
contradictions
and when you start doing that you start
to realize very quickly that okay all of
these
these views they may make sense on a
level but
on another level when you scratch below
the surface it just all falls apart
you know it all falls apart like take
liberalism for example
you know it's appealing from one
perspective
especially to the youth because when
you're young it makes sense you can
you can do what you want enjoy yourself
as long as you don't harm someone else
you know but if you get older as you get
older and you become you know
um you you go you become 60 70 years old
well then it's not appealing anymore
because it doesn't make sense for that
generation
you know and then you run into the
problem of loneliness which is rampant
especially in the west especially in the
uk it's one of the biggest killers
so you know any of these ideologies you
look into them you start to notice that
these floors on some level
um and you also notice that they they're
geared or set up to meet
a specific objective uh which may not be
may not be putting you first but maybe
putting a particular particular system
or a way of looking at things first and
you just sold this idea because it
allows you to be a cog in the system
in a way um and as long as you're so
ignorant of the details it's all good
um you know you could be used um but as
soon as you look into these things
further and really study them then
things become clear
you know so that's where i get people to
start really look into these ideologies
that you're ascribing to
you know do they fulfill you you know if
they do on what level do they fulfill
you will they continue to fulfill you in
in the next 10 years 20 years time
um you know and and do they make sense
to you
deep down inside you know as as a human
being
when you inquire about these things
become clear yeah you know what it is
too
i think it has to do with the society
and the environment and the people that
they're around and it's more so like
they didn't choose it it's just
something that was around them and they
accepted it because everyone else was
doing it yeah
yeah it's big that's big that's big that
social proofing
aspect of is massive you know most
people where the sheep
you know we follow we don't stop and
think okay is this the right thing
you know if you start to start doing
that especially
you know as muslims we're encouraged to
think be people that think and reflect
and inquire about things if you start to
do that things become clear
a hundred percent sure bro
before we go a little deeper i got a
personal question so we started this
podcast six months ago
and we there were a couple times where i
realized that reinforcing
and just having times where i'm
reflecting our main intention with the
podcast was very important
that relates back to this video that i
saw you um you were talking about how
there was a period in your life where
you were getting a little too caught up
with the numbers
right and there are phases that i could
relate to that too so do you want to go
into that
what what happened with with the whole
dalla thing was it even related to dao
or just youtube in general
it's it's both bro to be very honest
because the tawa if you think about the
dao
it's always public facing you know
whether it's you're speaking to one
person in a
you know in inside a house or whether
you're on youtube you're always public
facing to a degree
um so your your intention is always
going to be at risk
and intention as we know is one of the
most difficult things to get right you
know it's not easy
um so and especially when you're public
facing it becomes even more difficult
and you know the ego we live in we live
in times where the ego is really put on
a pedestal
it's all about the self you know when we
talk about the self we're not talking
about
our true essence as human beings the
soul you know
what allah breathed into us when we talk
about the self
in today's world it's referring to that
self identity the ego
that that's developed within our minds
through life experiences in our
association with things
so you know it's very easy to fall into
this trap and especially with youtube
bro
you know it's i mean it's it's very
difficult so i went through that phase
as well where
you know you it's it's subtle it happens
slowly over time
you know you start to look at the
numbers and you start to look at the
subscribers and you start to then think
about these things and then
over time it becomes it's almost like
you start justifying it to yourself
oh i'm it's it's good to have numbers
it's good to have viewers it's good to
have some subscribers because you're
getting the message out to more people
so you start justifying it to yourself
like that and you know and
as human beings we we ca we have this
tendency we can be
we can be very self-deceptive and we can
convince ourselves of so
really absurd things sometimes so it's
and that's how it happened with me and
then over time before you know it you
know your
your intentions all over the place and
you're just and you're
you're running on empty because i mean
especially when you do things
in the dean and you you know you want to
do something for islam
it has even a bigger impact because when
you're not being sincere and you're
not doing it for the right reasons
you're not going to have that energy
you're not going to have that that
strength to carry on
um and the only thing that feeds you at
a point then is the number of viewers
and then when you don't have enough
views on a certain video
you get depressed you get sad you know
you get upset
um you start questioning your own
existence to a degree right so
it's it's dangerous it's very dangerous
um it's a tool
you know it's a tool it's it's it's it's
it's
like a knife you know you can use a
knife to cut bread but you can use it to
kill someone
so when we use youtube we have to be
careful
um and we have to more than careful we
have to be we have to be conscious
of ourselves you know and and really sit
down and really think about
things or think things through before we
do them and we see this in the doubt bro
i'm very sort of you know as i get older
i become less um
it's it's not look let me put it this
way it's
the dawah scene online generally
speaking is in a bit of a mess at the
moment bro because a lot of things are
being justified under the
term dawa under the umbrella of dawah
you know and
you see these things sometimes and it's
you just you just think what is the
intention behind this why are people
doing these things
um and we don't we're not considering
the sort of long-term implications of
that
for us in this life and the hereafter
you know it's it's dangerous especially
but this is why we have to be cognizant
we have to be conscious
uh we have to have awareness of allah
you know we should and we should be
present we should be
you know really think take a moment
before we do anything and ask ourselves
okay
why am i doing this is this really
beneficial for the dawah
you know is it already being done if
someone else is doing it then do i need
to do it
and if i'm still doing it then what's my
thinking behind that and just be
spend a bit of time thinking about these
things be a bit more organized with
uh your your you know your thought
process and then inshallah these things
will help in the long run but i did
struck i did struggle from that a lot
and i know loads of people in the tawa
especially these days are struggling
from this and it has
more than one reason you know the other
reason is i mean
sincerity if you think about the concept
of sincerity
you know for me one of the most
fundamental things that's going to
determine
how close you get to being sincere is
your relationship with allah you know
you can't be sincere towards someone you
don't know
or that you have you know you're close
to it's very difficult
so the more you know allah the closer
you are to him the more you recognize
your relationship with allah
you know where you stand in the grand
scheme of things that you are his slave
he is your creator you know that you you
we come from nothing and we're gonna
return to nothing
you know it really sort of debases the
ego from that perspective and it really
helps with sincerity so
inshallah um but so yes as long as we're
conscious
i mean i mean we have to use these tools
you know but we have to be careful at
the same time
um so yeah that's that's all my thoughts
on that
do you think that lack of conscious or
being in the present moment
is a big contributing factor to the
attachment to the social media
validation that we talked about
yeah absolutely bro i mean all aspects
of life i mean we don't we're not
present
you know and this islam teaches us this
i mean we hear this from some new age
spiritualists today you know be present
in the moment
don't lose yourself in the past don't
lose yourself in the future
but this is a base concept in islam as
well i mean when allah speaks about
those who are successful in the quran
you know it's those who are who have
hashia in salah
in their prayer you know and how do you
have how do you have this humbleness and
awareness in prayer you have to be
present
if you're not present you're not going
to be you're not going to be humble
you're not going to be submissive you're
not going to be connecting with allah if
your mind is in the future somewhere
worrying about something
also crying about something that
happened two days ago so
it's being present is key you know and
it's
it's the route to a lot of problems that
we face
you know and a lot of you know haphazard
things that we do in our life sometimes
that we don't stop
and just really stop and think you know
um and
sometimes not even think just be aware
of your current situation
what's going on you know where am i
right now internally where's my heart
um so if we just to do this i think it
will really help
it makes me think uh to
certain situations in my life where when
i'm not
present things will happen right
like let's say uh i get injured
i do mma so i get injured i get a groin
injury
and in my mind i'm like oh man like this
is gonna
stop me from training i gotta take x
amount of time off
i gotta do all this stuff but it's like
all that's really happening
let me just make sure i got this good
here but um all that's really happening
is uh the intention since the intention
wasn't there
then allah is like okay well let me
humble you
let me bring you back and because the
presence
is also not there we fail to
recall allah and all we're recalling
is the uh the lesson the trial
and that brings us deeper into the trial
and makes the trial
expand and we just get consumed by it
versus
coming back to that awareness of allah
and then coming back to
i guess the full presence to where you
have the
the intention set pro appropriately
[Music]
i don't know that's what you reminded me
of i don't know if this uh completely
aligns with what we're talking about i
just had to throw it out there
nice deep robe is your you you're
absolutely right it's you know
and it reflects in all areas of life and
sometimes a lot of the problems we end
up in and we suffer from
is because of our lack of attention you
know
in doing things you know to start with
um
and it's same with you know loads of
people suffer from you know i
like i can't feel that connection with
allah you know i can't feel that
spirituality
again it stems it boils down to the same
thing it's like
are we present like when we look at
allah tells us reflect upon nature look
at the world around you
you know his signs are all around you
but we can't see them we we're so
desperate in finding that that perfect
philosophical argument that would prove
or like this and bring us some
type of validation but i mean how often
do we
when how often do we you know these days
especially go out and just spend some
time in nature and just be present
you know look at a tree for example and
without any sort of previous baggage in
our minds any of the
you know stuff that maybe else may be
going oh evolution or the scientist told
me this or this happened or that
happened
i mean just don't think and just look at
that that tree for a second
you know and really let it sink in you
know this is a living organism it's it's
in it and it has a purpose it has
benefits it gives us oxygen
takes in carbon dioxide etc you know and
just be there with the with with what
allah has created
you know and that that itself would lead
to a deep sort of spiritual
um awakening in people but we don't do
it we're so busy
like we said worrying about the future
what's going to happen where am i going
to go tomorrow
when's my next meeting or you know
crying about
being depressed about what happened in
the past and we're not here
like right now you know that and that's
the key it's like being here being
present and that's what thaqua boils
down to so what is taqwa
you know being conscious of allah aware
of allah
you know it's and that there's a very
beautiful narration
i think it was uh
who either said this or asked this
question to another companion
about taqwa and what was how he
understood he said it's like
you know when you're about to sort of
traverse and go through this
thorny path with there's loads of thorny
bushes and you so gather your clothing
just to make sure when you're going
through it that you don't get caught
somewhere your clothing doesn't get cold
your skin doesn't get torn you know it's
so it's about being
you have to be present you have to be
aware of everything and aware of allah
and it's going to come when you really
try to relax a bit and not it's not
worry so much about
you know what's happened or what will
happen
so what do you think pulls people away
from taqwa
there's that's uh there's probably loads
of things bro um one of the
one of the key things is it's just the
the fast pace fast pace of life today
that you know we experience
you know it's all about because we got
to remember the context we live in a
world
which is designed in a very specific way
you know especially after the the period
of enlightenment of you know the 18th
and 19th century
the the objective that was set
and and given to human beings was
worldly progress
you know it's about creating paradise on
earth you know as opposed to
wanting to attain paradise in the
hereafter so you have to bring paradise
to earth literally and
you know you have to make your life as
comfortable as you can as luxurious as
you can have as much money as you can
have as many material possessions as you
can and that's what defines success
that's your purpose
now with that in mind you know obviously
you know it's gonna
that philosophy is gonna affect even the
muslims to a certain degree because
we live in this world you know we go
through the same educational
institutions we go through
we experience everything else every
other person experiences
so that doesn't help because we're
always thinking about
how do i you know buy the next car how
do i save for this
what else do i need to you know purchase
for amazon and
and you know make sure i have you know
we're trying to outdo other people you
see and you and
you see this with neighbors i mean in
the in the uk i don't know if it's the
same
way you guys are but when you walk down
certain streets
you'll notice that you know if if one
one person one house on the street has
like a certain fire alarm
you know a certain system in place the
next five or six houses would have the
same system in place
you know and then you'll find a house
that has lots like solar panels on the
roofs and then the next five or six
houses would have solar panels in the
roof
you know so it's always trying to outdo
each other compete with each other
and and this is something this creates a
lot of worry and stress and and it takes
a lot of focus
you know it draws your attention away
from what's important which is
knowing your creator worshiping him you
know being present
being aware of allah subhanahu wa trying
to do what's good as opposed to what's
bad
and there's a lot of distractions in the
world that we live you know it's it's
it's full of distractions and it's very
hard
and that's why mashallah what you guys
are doing on these podcasts you know
uh reaching out to the youth and really
trying to sort of help them out
you know with their journey in islam
and through their lives is very powerful
bro and
people need to be aware of these things
man
you know it's it's sad when you see it
you know you see someone that's
memorized the entire quran for example
you know and i've come across people
like this and they've memorized the
entire quran
yet they their faith is on edge you know
they're like i don't know if i believe
anymore
you know i mean it's it's it and why is
it happening it's happening because of
all these reasons you know we're not
really paying attention
we're not focusing on the basics we're
not understanding what allah is saying
in the quran
you know quran i mean we don't read it
we don't spend time with the quran
you know it's sad it's it's a shock it's
these are the words of allah this is
what we believe this is a revelation
from god which is preserved
well why aren't we then spending time
with it you know
it's the best self-help book that's
available on the face of this earth
there ever will be yet we rather read
self-help books written by written by
certain gurus and certain people
other human beings who are as limited as
us and may experience the same problems
as us
you know but we don't take the time to
read the book of allah
you know so i mean we're shooting
ourselves in the foot in some ways
in some ways it's the environment the
world that we live in you know which
distracts us and then there's many other
factors
many many other factors that leads me to
the next question
where it's like all right let's say
someone
isn't involved in the fast-paced
lifestyle like
the gentleman that you just mentioned
where he's learning the entire quran
but then he's getting to the point where
he's over here
dwindling in his iman is it is it your
mom or
no is he mine yeah my bad i'm still
learning bro i'm sorry
yeah inshaallah insha allah but
um yeah so this person he's learning the
quran
he doesn't have the fast-paced lifestyle
but yet his taqwa is dwindling his iman
is dwindling like what then what would
you say is
his issue do you think it's uh something
to do with
the spirituality part where he he's
getting so much into
obviously recalling the quran is amazing
but he's getting so much
into the rational logistic side that
they're failing to get that spiritual
side that spiritual connection
it's it's yeah so i think one of the
issues is is that
we have this tradition especially in
certain parts of the world like for
example
i could speak for pakistan and and and
this asian subcontinent mainly
where you would learn the quran you may
memorize the entire quran but
there won't be any emphasis on
understanding what the quran is saying
you know what is allah saying what's the
message because the quran is guidance
you know allah says it's guidance for
mankind
well if it's guidance then guidance
needs to be understood you know you
can't call something guidance unless you
you have no clue what it's saying you
know it's not going to guide you at
least
so there's a lack of emphasis on
on really understanding the quran in
your language you know there's many
translations available but people don't
think it important in some places in the
world or don't give it the same amount
of emphasis as other things
so that is a def big problem and
definitely there are muslims out there
who memorize the entire quran in arabic
yet they don't know what it means you
know there's many people like this and
that is a problem fundamentally that's
an issue
um the other thing is it's it's and it
goes back to the point about
the world that we live in it's like what
is your who is your god
you know what is your illah in the
arabic the the word itself referring to
you know the being that's greater than
you and the being that you rely upon
and depend upon what is your god what
have you made your god every human has a
god
you know by we can't escape this
everyone submits to something
everyone worships something you know for
some people it's materialism for others
it's another person for some it may be
you know some type of ideology or view
everyone is submitting to something
everyone is obeying something
that's a fundamental question who are
you obeying what are you worshiping
i mean a lot of times and this is the
thing because we don't understand
tawheed
the concept of the oneness of allah and
that allah alone is the creator
you know he is the only being that's
maintaining everything and in control of
everything and then logically he's the
one that we should worship
i mean why would we as rational human
beings worship or submit to something
inferior you know something that's not
any better than we are as
you know as limited beings you know we
should worship allah alone but
because we don't understand this we end
up taking other
beings you know as objects of worship
and sometimes not even knowing that
we're doing that
you know or not being aware of that and
that causes a lot of problems
and sometimes also to add to this it's
also sins
you know desires you know some people
allah says in the quran have you not
seen the one that's taken his own
desires
as lord as a god you know and this is
it's a powerful ayah if you think about
it's a powerful verse because
you know sometimes some people would
take themselves as lord you know i mean
typical example
and it's probably a bit of a stereotype
but you will get some atheists
who would say you know i don't worship
anything i don't follow anyone
i do what i want to do you know all your
your the clues in what you've just said
you're submitting to yourself
your base desires you know what the
voice from inside
you know so you're not in any better
position than someone that's worshiping
a stone or a statue or an idol
so you know it's it's about really
understanding that allah is the only
being worthy of worship
he's the only creator they only maintain
and submitting to him
you know and and we have to as human
beings take that first step
you know allah is allah is free of need
as he says he doesn't need us
you know he doesn't need our worship he
doesn't need us to praise him or glorify
him
he's completely independent of these
things we are in need of him as human
beings
you know and when we realize this you
know
that you know it's like i always give
the example you know if you have a car
and you buy a car that's designed to run
on petrol right so you drive it around
it's a really nice car
and as soon as you run out of petrol you
have this sort of genius idea you think
you know what i'm not going to put
petrol in the tank i'm going to go home
i'm going to get a bottle of water and
put water in the tank
i mean what's going to happen the car is
going to break down you know so
we as human beings we're designed to run
off something
you know physically we have certain
things that we need to run off like food
water etc but spiritually we also
have needs and requirements and we have
to we have this
something that we have to run off and
that is allah worshiping allah that's
what we were created to do
so if we don't do this we're gonna have
problems we're gonna have issues you
know
if we don't focus on the basics and
really understand who allah is why we
were created all of these things we're
gonna have problems in iman
especially if we have we're submitting
to other things we're fulfilling our
desires we're engaging in sins
all of these things are going to sort of
dampen and cover the heart
so you're not going to be able to
connect and when you're not connected
you know or you don't your heart's
covered and you don't have that
spiritual connection
of course you're gonna have doubts
coming into your mind and problems and
issues and
questions you know so um yeah
i i guess that's those are a few reasons
why you may find someone that
may have memorized the quran entirely
but still yet suffer from
a low iman or two who may end up in a
position where they're just not sure
anymore don't know what to do what to
believe
so are you married right now or married
with kids
married with kids made with kids with
kids kids right now
bless your family so tell me something
about
you know a couple lessons that you
learned from being a father and a
husband
that's a really good question no one's
asking a question before
um bro i only asked that because a lot
of viewers along
with me like a couple years ago i would
look at you and be like okay you look
like you're like 23 24.
no i'm 33 bro i'm the lila i'm 33 years
old man
i'm dylan i may just be the camera it's
good this may be this contrast
camera bro keep that around so when
you're like 90 you look like you're 60.
inshallah bro
good advice man so what i've learned
from
marriage and fatherhood um
patience is one of the biggest lessons
you learn you know especially with kids
man
you know children can be really testing
so just to have patience you know and
also responsibility bro
you know responsibility is a big thing
you know um
just to be responsible for someone other
than yourself is is massive
you know and
again responsibility is one of those
things that we don't really want to take
these days
you know that's why you see people don't
want to get married you know they don't
want to
be responsible for the community etc
responsibility is massive
that's those that's one of the biggest
things two things i've learned patience
and responsibility
how long have you been married now
probably i think close to and i'm
terrible with dates bro so that's what
i'm having to think about this
uh maybe i think it's it's been over
seven years now
seven eight years your wife watching
this right now probably like
imran man come on yeah i know i'm
terrible i i don't remember birthdays
but one of the things
that's just this advice i have if you
like i just can't remember dates man i'm
just terrible with dates
dates and names those are the two things
i just can't remember
so i feel like i have a question here
but i don't think
it might be appropriate i was gonna
ask god
okay because um i was gonna ask you is
the marriage is marriage what you
thought it would be
and i was gonna ask you like is it like
a relationship but then again like
you're born muslim so i don't know if
you ever had just a relationship
because i understand that that's haram
to have just a relationship
so i'll say this right when i wasn't
muslim i was living like everyone else
was living so yeah i
you know may have had some relationships
et cetera right with
with people um what was the other
was the sorry what was the basically
asking like an islamic marriage
is it like a relationship in a way like
how in today's secular and non-muslim
world we have just
people dating and all that it's
again it comes back to responsibility
bro man it's like you have to be real
with it
so there is that what they call the
honeymoon period right which is the
maybe the first
you know it depends it varies you can
say the first year some people say the
first couple of months etc
right so you there is that period and
there's nothing wrong with it i mean
you know brothers and sisters when they
get married they should enjoy that
period right but they should be
practical as well
you know because a relationship between
two people
a husband and a wife it's it's deeper
than that it's deeper than that initial
infatuation
and those you know those those feelings
that you have initially
um and be ready for that you know that's
the best piece of advice to give
brothers is that because before they get
married they're really excited and they
think it's going to be like a bollywood
movie
you know it's just never going to end
and those feelings are never going to
change or anything like that but
you know it feelings change but it gets
that's not in a negative way
it gets deeper right so it's it the love
becomes deeper it's not just superficial
it's not just based on how you look
you know or or what i like about you
your personality it's deeper than that
you know it's it's and it's a beautiful
thing in and of itself
um so yeah it's it's uh
it's and it's it's beautiful also
because you know we realize that allah
has
he's put a system in place so the
marriage has a dynamic
you know this give and take on something
both
for both parties for the for the husband
and the wife
you know and you have to and you also
also have to be
you know forgiving you have to have true
forgiveness you know you have to be
you have to overlook you know sometimes
and you can't be
you can't be rigid in your marriage you
know if you if you're rigid you'll break
the marriage will break you know so you
have to be practical pragmatic
you have to relax you know you you just
just you know there'll be times where
your spouse may do something you don't
like
you know and it may be a minor thing
don't just let it go you know you have
to be
i mean you have to be gentle with this
and
marriage develops in a very beautiful
way you know if you especially if you
conduct it with within the islamic
framework you know it develops and it
becomes deeper
and and much more meaningful you know
and especially when you have children
then it's this another element that
comes in is this partnership between the
husband and wife to
raise your children properly you know so
again
it's it's a it's it's a beautiful system
you know that allah has put in place
and and men need women and women need
men you know we're not complete without
the other
you know and again it's just it's a sign
because you know
every aspect of our lives it's we can't
behold
as an individual there's only one it's
allah he's alone
you know he does he's free of need as
human beings we we have needs you know
and and women complement men and men
compliment women in their own ways so
you know but it's within the framework
of islam which which
and then expands out to the society as
well it's what's best for society
you know but what we see you know in it
and being practiced
otherwise you know it's it's it's
detrimental on many levels you know
when you people just have relationship
after relationship it has it has an
impact on people
their perceptions and and all of this so
um
it's what i would say is is it's just to
summarize i guess is
be practical know that there's going to
be the initial honeymoon period enjoy
that
make the most of it don't be like oh i
know it's going to be over get it i'm
not going to
you know it's just transient no enjoy
each phase in your marriage
you know it's it's going to bring
something new and it's going to be
meaningful in its own way
are you guys married by the way no yeah
it is
you married masala no sir
no no yeah okay
yeah very soon oh but question man uh
actually i'll take that back if if i if
it comes back
inshallah i will throw it in there but
my mind just went blank
you talked about marriage thought about
women and my mind went blank man
may allah make it easy for you very soon
inshallah
i mean with that being said
let's imagine someone like angel most
brothers today they want to get married
right
but we live in a we live in a society
where it could be because of the way
culture is it could be the way parents
are that haram is becoming very easy
and at our fingertips and halal is
becoming very difficult
so what are some of the factors that you
think are leading it to the way it is
right now
i think the muslim community is to blame
to an extent it's that we don't have
the infrastructures in place to make it
easy for brothers and sisters right
um just and that could be as easy as a
mosque you know they have a little
project in place where you know if a
brother wants to get married they can go
and speak to the imam and then you know
there's a system in place where
that could be set up it can happen
inshallah um
and then obviously again i can't speak
for every community but you're speaking
about the asian community specifically
man these issues bro like we have this
like the parents make it difficult you
know the brother wants to get married
you know he's
you know he's he's 20 years old 22 years
old maybe younger you know he's hormonal
obviously we're human you've got
hormones they're raging you know make it
easy for them yeah so just
if you want to get married but no it's
like you know you've got to get you got
to finish your education you've got to
get a good job you've got to get a place
and when all of these things are placed
in place then come back to me and we
think about it
you know i will come back to me and i'll
get you married to
my friend's daughter who's you know who
i've promised him already you're gonna
get married
so there's so many issues like i mean
parents need to make it easy for the
kids
yeah um and and that means when they
if they have if they feel comfortable to
approach you and tell you they want to
get married then facilitate that for
them you know make it easy for them
don't make it more difficult for people
um so that's on a sort of family dynamic
level
on a social level amongst the muslim
community maybe it's easy in canada but
in the uk i mean it's still very
difficult
most you know as far as i'm aware most
most don't have something in place
like they don't know where to go like
many brothers they don't know who to ask
you know because i mean it's it's a big
thing marriage you know it's not
something in islam that you can get
married today and you know get divorced
tomorrow
just because you know whatever you need
to consider things right you need to
make sure that you're getting married to
the right person
so that means you have to come across
the right person and that needs to be
you know facilitated um
so yeah to all those factors man i think
it's it causes issues and problems and
like you said there's so much
haram in our environment in our society
and it's all around bro i mean you go
down to walk down the street and you'll
see like six billboards
where uh women are being objectified and
used to sell a product
i mean it's and and if you're a guy then
it's gonna be an issue
because it's a part of your nature as as
as a man
so you know it's it considering
just how overly sexualized society is
today
uh we need to try to make it easier
for our youth to get married when
they're ready
and to take their responsibility um and
so they can mature as well because
marriage like i said it matures you as a
human being man it makes you responsible
you know it may it actually you know
from a from a guy's perspective it makes
you a man
in a way in many ways you know because
you you're not only worrying about
yourself you have to take care of people
now
you know you have a family to to support
um so it's it's it's a good thing bro
it's a good thing
you know so and it should be facilitated
and made easy for
for our younger generation
[Music]
you've you've let me remember
what i was going to ask you earlier
which was
i want to get your take on this all
right because i have my take and i'm
sure fired as his
but i want to know what you think as uh
what
problems come about from uh this whole
basically dating like you go from one
relationship to the next one to the next
one to the next one
or you're going from like one marriage
to the next marriage to the next
marriage to the next marriage like
what implications does this have on the
individuals
that are partaking in this
so one of the things i would say it's it
it messes with your psychology
you know as as a male and a female you
know because
relationships you know there's something
that by the very nature supposed to be
meaningful
you know there's something that's
nurtured and supposed to grow over time
when you're jumping from person to
person to to person
i mean you're you're short-circuiting
yourself you're messing with your wiring
as well as a human being
i mean you know you lose respect for the
opposite gender to a degree
you know if for for guys women just
become
you know just just this you know
this just this this being or creature
that they're supposed to
you know get with and get whatever they
want from them and that's it move on
you know i can't put it in any other way
um and
for women i mean the
male and female psychology is different
right no and this is
one of those big things i mean it's not
to say one is better than the other
not at all you know but men and women
are different i mean we have to
recognize this and i know the feminists
have
have have some really distorted ways of
looking at things um especially when it
comes to equality
um but you can't run away from this i
mean if you look at the psychological
research on this the scientific research
on this men and women are different
you know psychologically physically
emotionally women have certain traits
guys don't have
you know they're much more emotionally
intelligent you know they're much more
aware
emotionally insensitive and that's a
that's an amazing trait to have
and guys have certain traits that women
don't have but so
i think from a purely female perspective
a woman's perspective
and i can't say much but
i mean i can't see it doing anything
good for her she's having to go from one
person to another person to a third
person
it must really mess with with the female
psychology you know and
it's not a good thing in in any way
shape or form bro we lose respect for
each other we objectify each other in
ways which is not true
and then in the long run you're gonna
have problems in your when you do want
to settle down you know
because you're just not gonna know how
to do that you know and on top of it you
just
you're not gonna be getting those
immediate thrills that you may get from
a short-term relationship
so what do you do then you're because
you've spoiled spoiled yourself
in a certain way and you're going to
have issues problems
and then obviously psychologically it
damages you to a degree i mean how many
two times the good you know
relationships where the intention is for
it to last
end because of you know previous
experiences
you know that the the the sister the
woman has had
some really bad traumatic experiences
when they tried to make they may have
fallen in love with the guy
who messed the rock messed her around
you know that's going to impact the
relationship in the future
you know so it it destroys these these
these sort of delicate
structures within society it really
messes and what up
and then kids if they have children the
poor children suffer because of this
whole
you know situation and then they go on
and that so
colors their thinking as well you know
because children like sponges bro
you know when they see that their
parents are split or they're fighting
and arguing and it's not working
it's going to leave a lasting impression
in their minds which later in their
lives can affect them negatively as well
100 you make me recall in my own
experience
and you know i revert in
closing in on a year now alhamdulillah
but i feel like the experiences that i
had with like
multiple women has like tainted me
and uh is very and i speak very honestly
here but
it is very difficult um looking at
muslimas and and trying to choose
at least one for a wife and because i
i'm telling you like
i was with women that were like
instagram models
at least i perceived them i perceived
them like that and it's like bro
like when you go from there and then
like obviously in islam you don't have
these women that are portraying
themselves like this or
beautifying themselves like this you
know for the most for the world
yeah yeah for the most part for the most
part um
it's just weird bro and like i find
myself
turning down opportunities because
of my past experiences where i'm like
well i had something like this and this
sounds very shallow and i'm gonna admit
it it probably is very shallow but it's
like i'll see
the woman and it's just i'm like oh i
i've i've had better like i'm sorry to
say that but i've had better and
i do feel like it's tainted me so like i
can only imagine what it does for
people who who don't come to islam and
who stay
in that secular way yeah man it's big i
mean we're human at the end of the day
in it so it's gonna it's gonna have
you know it's going to have these
implications and loads of brothers bro
like i mean even non-practicing muslims
when they come start practicing again
and they want to get married they have
similar issues i mean it's um and and
the only thing you can
well there's a couple of things you can
do in such a situation
and it's difficult i mean it's easy to
say but i mean
psychologically and emotionally it's
very difficult
is is one of the things is to just
give yourself the bigger picture which
is you know
i need to be with someone who has a good
character and has a good heart
you know and i know it's easy to say
because you know the
the you know the you need they have to
and islam encourages this the person
you're going to get married to has to be
physically attractive
to you is all i mean that's a part of it
as well so may allah make it easy bro
i'll give you that balance sha allah and
give you the right partner inshallah
very soon
yeah i mean i mean i mean i wanted to
touch on one thing you said earlier
yes men and women are different but
allah made them different right it's
beautiful it doesn't have to be a
competition that
you know men are better and you know
everything women are better everything
men are better in some areas women are
better in some areas and there's a
reason
you know why that is the way it is right
that being said though
um you mentioned that
being in these relationships just going
from relationship to relationship
it does take a toll on your psychology
right would you
do you think it affects one sex more
than the other
and i only ask that because in islam
allah allows
you know men to be poligionous you know
there's a certain different amount of
criteria
but that ability is still there
does it affect one sex more than the
other like a woman going
through a bunch of different
relationships does it does just affect
her
psychology biochemistry whatever you
want to call it um
with men period compared to a man that
would go through the same thing
generally speaking i'd say yes so what i
mean by that is
if you take if you just generalize right
because women
do get connected more they they do
invest
more so quicker than men do in a
relationship
now again i'm going to use this word but
i need to contextualize it they they are
more emotional
um but what i mean by that is that they
they
they're more in tune with their feelings
um so i'm not saying in a negative way
right
um and they it and therefore
as an extension because they've
committed and given themselves to the
person
and and invested in that person it's
much more difficult for but then again
brothers there are some brothers who are
very emotional and sensitive as well
you know some guys have that type of
nature too where they're very sort of
emotional and emotionally in tune with
people so
generally speaking yes i would say it
affects women more
but i think there are you know men that
are affected really badly
from such experiences or having
different relationships
um but yeah like you said bro um men and
women you know
it's a very beautiful point and you know
you summarize it which is they're
different
but it doesn't mean one difference
doesn't lodge it doesn't logically
follow
just because two things are different
that one is better than the other
you know i mean and that's how some
people would want to see it or you're
saying there's a difference therefore
you're saying that men are better than
women no
you know they're different some you know
men have some qualities which
women don't have and women have certain
qualities that men don't have or may not
have
the opposition they may not have the
same degree of that quality within
do you think society plays a role in
shaming men
for not having some qualities that women
have from a very young age and
vice versa shaming women for a lot of
their qualities that they're born with
in the natural fitra by allah and for
not having the qualities that
men have yeah i think across the board
meant for men and women
okay because we have again what the the
the one of the underlying philosophical
ideas is is of quality from a sort of
liberal sense
of the word and an equal opportunity is
an equal you know
uh outcome for both men and women um so
it's almost like
the world we live in today doesn't want
to recognize anymore to
so fundamental differences between men
and women
not to say that one is better than the
other that's not what we're saying
but that there are differences they
don't want to recognize because
you know especially this whole feminist
movement it's it's all about
you know being equal across the board
and they don't really define that and
they don't really look at the
implications of what they're saying
either sometimes
you know so it's um it's it's definitely
men are shamed for certain things and
women too
are shameful certain things you know so
it's uh
and this is the thing again when you're
on your information and your way of
looking at the world is coming from
the human mind a subjective perspective
on what you think is right
given the time you're you live in in
history
uh you're gonna have problems because it
all boils down to human subjectivity
you know as opposed to when you're
referring to allah the creator of men
and women
you know and therefore he is the source
that's going to be able to tell us the
differences
you know and and tell us the qualities
and tell us how
they can work with each other to to to
benefit themselves and benefit society
um so yeah i think it does definitely
does to answer your question
i'm the bro i just paused because i
don't know i had a question
no yeah all right let's let's say you
know you're in a center
you have a son and you have this idea in
your in your mind
being a practicing muslim that you want
to be unashamed in the fact that you
want
your son to grow up to be a man and
you know not in any way there's no
there's no definition of a man there's
no one definition i don't want to say
this is what a man is
if you have to you know act like a man
then you're not a man what i'm saying is
you want him to be a man society's
telling him if
you know he doesn't want to be like that
it's okay matter of fact they're
encouraging that
how do you how do you keep that in your
mind how do you keep that in check in
your household how do you
have that conscious intention that you
know you want to guide him to be a
proper man by the quran and sunnah
but society is out here you know kind of
pulling him to the seams at times to the
other direction
i think i think like you said there's no
sort of clear definition what does it
mean to be a man
right there's some notions that we have
right which are so very intuitive and
you may
you know may have been are represented
even within society or used to be
um but i think that's that's a far too
big of a question i mean if we start
trying to figure out how we define what
a man is we'll be here for a very long
time but i think
what i would what i would do personally
what i try to do is
when my kids are old old enough to
understand is to get them to try to
understand
the source of islam like who is islam
from okay
it's from allah okay so what does that
mean now it's from the all-knowing
creator
therefore logically what god says is
true right it is necessarily follows if
it comes from allah then it must be true
so try to live your lives according to
the quran for my daughter and my son
right so and if they both do that then i
think
you know it's there's a natural
development for men and women within the
quran
you know um and and it's almost like
they'll naturally be able to understand
their roles and responsibilities um and
try to fulfill them to the best of their
ability
as opposed to having to to to tell them
specifically you know this is what it
means to be a man so and if they're
following
what islam teaches then whenever they do
come across certain ideas in society
which you know um
may be incorrect they'll be able to sort
of weigh in
and evaluate with what allah said you
know
so i think core concepts is key bro it's
like
giving kids those core concepts you know
and that doesn't mean
you know do this or don't do that you
know because with kids if you tell them
do this don't do that
it's not really going to help and i
think that causes a lot of problems
amongst muslims as well you know and
many people ex-muslims if you like or
you know people that muslims have left
islam one of the biggest things is oh
why does god want me to why should i do
this why should i do that why should i
pray five times a day you know why
should i fast in ramadan
it all boils down to the fundamental
issue they haven't understood
the source of this religion and what
that therefore implies
you know if it's from allah the
all-knowing all-powerful creator
you know the one that wants best for us
the one that loves us
then therefore it logically follows
whatever he said is true therefore i
should follow it to the best of my
ability
regardless of whether i completely
understand
you know all of the wisdoms behind it
all the logic behind it all of the
rationale behind it it's irrelevant
you know because as human beings
sometimes as allah says sometimes we
want
things which are bad for us and we don't
realize it you know from our perspective
and sometimes we want things
we don't want things which may be
actually good for us um so
i think just giving kids core concepts
and allowing them to understand why
islam is true
and then encouraging them to follow it
to the best of their ability as they
grow and develop i think that's the
solution to all of these issues bro
i think it's very important as well to
add to your wonderful point that
it's good to start young too you know
you know if you start
later and you want to enforce boundaries
later it's a little confusing to kids
right
you don't want to have a kid who you
know they come home you know
raised in today's west they they wear
whatever you want and then you you quote
them in the hadith by the prophet
so i'm talking specifically about men
that dress like women and women that
dress like men they're gonna be like
like what it's it's almost too late i
don't want to say it's too late because
you know a lot of guys
we wills but it's better as parents that
we take that role on earlier than
after things already hit the fan yeah
and
look it's his this will always you know
sort of whenever such
people come up with such little
questions or issues
you know about why do this or why do
that why
dress like this or dress like that why
do women have to cover in a certain way
and men don't have to cover in the same
way
you know it's let's understand the
fundamental issue here
the real problem is who are you going to
follow are you going to follow the
creator of everything or you're going to
follow created beings
and their subjective opinions and ideas
you know which are
ever changing through throughout the
years decades centuries the
ever-changing world i mean
things that we consider to be okay in
today's society you know 2021
go back 10 years you know some of those
things at least some of those things
would not be considered okay
and normal go 10 years into the future
things will change again
you know morality their perspective on
what's right and wrong will change
because it's always based on the limited
human subjective mind
you know which can't give you absolutes
or clarity it's just
it's going to be opinion uh of certain
individuals then which is
spread through society and it becomes a
norm for a little while and then it
changes again you know
i mean who do you want to follow do you
want to follow subjective ideas and
opinions or do you want to follow what
the creator has told you
you know i mean rationally it makes
sense to follow the creator
as opposed to created beings and their
ideas and views
i just want to say bro uh
my mind has been boosted i feel like i
got an iman boost
having this conversation with you from
allah bless you bro
allah
speaking of iman boosters bro i think
you know given that we're
going towards the end of our timeline
let's end it
with this what advice would you have to
brothers and sisters who are dwindling
in their iman at times
so the very first thing is to realize
you know and come to terms with the fact
that you're dwindling because a lot of
times we put it off
you know so we may have some we may not
be practicing or may not be wanting to
pray on time
or pray properly we may be rushing it so
subtle things like this will happen
and in many cases we don't stop and
think okay i need to fix something
something
isn't right normally we just let it go
on right let it get worse
through the course of time so first
thing is to realize okay
you know you need to take you need to
evaluate you need to sit down and think
about what's wrong
and once you get to that sort of
conscious space in your mind and you
realize okay things need to be fixed
is then to realize that if you are
dwindling if you're having problems with
your iman
if you're not praying on time you don't
you know you don't want you know wanting
to do certain things
you realize it's happening for a reason
everything happens for a reason right so
what is the reason go go and search for
that reason okay
maybe it's society maybe it's my
environment maybe i'm engaging in too
many sins you know maybe
i'm doing things that you know i desire
and i know they're not right
you know could and i think if we've got
a couple of minutes i do want to sort of
uh explain you know this whole al
hamdulillah so i do want to explain this
whole
thing about doubts and confusions and
lack of iman and stuff
see the way i see doubts is you have
you can put doubts in two categories
right
doubts which are not really doubts
they're questions
right because sometimes we label the
question adult right and that's
problematic because as soon as you label
something
it becomes that thing for you right so
words are very powerful they have
meaning
and then that becomes a part of our
understanding so we have to be very
careful
if you have a question don't call it a
doubt
unnecessarily if it's a question it's a
question right and we should ask
questions as muslims we're encouraged to
ask questions there'll be many things we
don't know about we're going in search
of the answers
so re-label it first really ask yourself
is there a doubt or is there a question
now if you genuinely are having doubts
and issues and you know your your mind's
lacking
is you have to realize a lot of times
doubts stem from
two main things one is that we are not
studying our religion we're not really
looking into things and inquiring about
things and studying increasing our
knowledge
and the second thing is that we're
engaging in things and design fulfilling
our desires which are not you know we
shouldn't be doing
right so we're engaging in sins when you
engage in sins
what happens is is you start enjoying
those things right because they link to
your desires and they come up over and
over again
and the more you fulfill your desires
the more you sort of enjoy that process
and the more you get used to it
now there's this dissonance within your
mind within the person because on one
side
you know allah has told you not to do x
y and z and on the other side
you enjoy doing x y and z and you're
doing x y and z whatever that is
right and human being we don't like to
be in a state of dissonance as human
beings we like to have stability right
now when there's this tension within
your mind allah has told me to do this
but i am doing this and i'm enjoying
this
that's going to cause this this very
sort of agitated state within you not
going to be comfortable
so in that scenario you're going to end
up doing one or two things
you're either going to stop doing the
sins or try to stop doing those sins and
bring yourself back to the correct way
or you're gonna
turn away from islam and carry on with
your sins right
now unfortunately most people
end up going towards just carrying on
with the sins and turning away from
islam because it's
easier you know it's much easier to just
fulfill and give in to your desires and
that instant gratification
right as opposed to doing what's right
as as people
so we don't do what's right we don't we
take the easy route which is doing these
things now
to make things easy for yourself to get
rid of this dissonance in your mind
you have to turn away from islam right
now what ends up happening and this may
happen on a subconscious level
is that you will start to manufacture
doubts so that you can disassociate
from islam and carry on with your
desires and that makes so you'll try
convincing yourself oh
you know islam isn't true for x y z
reason okay it's not true i don't need
to worry anymore there's no
accountability there's nothing to worry
about let me i can go and do whatever i
want now and enjoy myself right
but we don't realize that we do this
deliberately is to get ourselves out of
this dissonance we start manufacturing
doubts and shaitan obviously plays a
role in this as well
right so is to really get to to the
bottom of it understand why you have
doubts
and then once you're conscious of it and
you're aware of what's going on then you
can start solving that problem
and and really you know take the
responsibility of solving that problem
no one's going to do it for you
you have to do it yourself and you allah
has given you the strength and the
ability
to resolve these issues he's made you
intelligent he's given you rational
faculties he's given you a heart
he's given you a soul you know he's
giving you the fitra
so you know be responsible
and face the challenge of solving your
issues you know and those are two things
we run away from we don't want to be
responsible
and we don't want to do things that are
difficult in today's world you know we
just want things to be easy
you know and we always do what's easy
even if it's wrong
you know so and being a muslim you know
especially being a muslim we have to
realize that we're moral beings
we're rational beings and it's therefore
a responsibility upon us to do what's
right
even if it's difficult even if it's hard
you know even if it takes effort
and just to do that and then you'll
realize when you do that that's when
you'll truly be happy
you know when you face your obstacles
you face your challenges and head on
and you you take them on and you take
them out that's when you're going to be
you know you're going to feel happy
truly happy and joyful
not when you give in to your desires and
you give in to what's easy you know and
do what's wrong
you're just going to be in this sort of
perpetual downward spiral
and just be depressed and sad and and
you know
it's not going to end somewhere good it
gives you that false sense
of uh the satisfaction and and about
pleasure
where it's like you do something and
it's like oh this feels good
you know like i wanted to do this it
feels good doing it
but then it's like it's very short-lived
and then once that's gone
you're right back to where you started
versus like if you are
doing things properly if you are reading
the quran if you are
praying you are present in your prayer
you have that taqwa
and you are truly in tune
with the creator like that's that's
different that doesn't leave you high
and dry
absolutely like the other ones yeah
absolutely bro and this
i mean it reminds me of a narration of
the prophet sallam
in regards to dajjal right it's a very
there's many things the prophet
said about dajjal which is in english
the antichrist as is translated
the deceiver that will come near the end
of times
he's he in one of the narrations the
prophet mentioned that the jal would
have
a heaven and a hell a jannah and a
jahannam with him
right and his jannah his paradise would
actually be hell
and his hellfire would actually be
paradise
right now i mean it's really interesting
from one way we live in times where
what's right and what's good is very
difficult
right it's almost like hell literally
like it's like you know hellfire itself
it's so difficult you know doing what's
right and it's so easy to do what's
wrong
you know it's so easy to indulge in
things which are wrong you know so it's
about being we have to be conscious that
we live in times where
you know it's all flipped you know
appearances are not the same as reality
and if we keep engaging the things that
are easy
i give you that quick you know instant
gratification in the long run you're
just going to be depressed
and you're going to be empty as a person
you know because you're not living up to
your potential
and if you do what's right as difficult
as it is as much as it may seem like
hell
you know you're gonna at the end of it
you're gonna feel good you know you're
gonna
actually feel proud of yourself for
doing the right things
man 100 of 100 see we have uh we have a
patreon
and you know our beginning tiers are
just they get our exclusive content
early you know
exclusive videos and our podcasts early
but we have some tiers where we involve
like
coaching with us the consultation calls
and a lot of the consultation calls we
do get from our patrons
um believe it or not bro the things we
tell them that are in line with the
quran and sunnah to the best of our
abilities
it already naturally resonates with
their fitra like
once we tell them they're like oh you
know i had a feeling you know like i
just needed that reassurance
and it's like when you say something
that just it just hits their soul just
for some reason they always know like
that was the issue anyway but they
couldn't put two and two together
maybe they were clouded by this thing
maybe their their lens was like hazy
maybe they were focusing on the wrong
things so it just reinforced the fact
that yes there is one objective truth
one objective reality one instruction
manual
sent from the the creator and we should
do what we can to the best of our
abilities to follow that
absolutely bro like you said it's the
fitra like you know allah says in the
quran
he you know in surah shams he said that
he says that you know after he created
the soul he inspired the soul with
an understanding of right and wrong so
it's innate
you know this under this this compass
that we have within us
but the world we live in today is trying
to sort of break that compass
so people lose that internal sense of
right and wrong and therefore it's
easier for them to engage in things
which are wrong without feeling any
guilt
or any internal sort of marker or check
that will inform them that what they've
done is wrong
so it's the fitra is always there bro
it's it's a power of a nature
you know so uh and like you said when
when you tell them what allah tells them
in the quran
what's the quran is in line with human
nature it's in line with the fitra
you know so it's just a case of you know
doing what's right
and having the courage to do that the
strength to do that
mashallah guys i just want to do a quick
plug right now
if you want to go deeper into the
concept of losing your iman
there's a wonderful khutba that i
watched by noman ali khan
it's called how we lose our iman right
it was posted about five years ago has
like
just under two million views so you know
you got the right video give that a
watch if if you want something that
hits your soul inshallah like that hit
me that was a video that i watched and i
was like damn bro like i never put two
and two together
all the puzzle pieces like came together
and it made sense like
you start feeling guilty because you're
addicted to your nufs just like you said
you're controlled by your desires you
took your desire there's god stuck for
allah
and you get to a point where it's like
the only thing making you feel guilty
is this is something and this islam
thing isn't really
that true anyway so why am i feeling
guilty
let me remove islam from the picture so
i can just do my nufs without feeling
any accountability
i'm paraphrasing but guys watch that for
sure
all right i don't know anything else
i said hi guys if you made it this far
comment down below hashtag bring
imran back because we gotta have part
two but
for your time man guys may i bless you
and uh
yeah mela makes a means for uh you know
of benefit for us
and for everyone else that watches
inshallah
all right any last few uh words or a
message you have
before we wrap it up no just keep going
man you guys are doing
amazing work mashallah you know reaching
out especially the demographic that's in
trouble
you know especially in the times that we
live in so it's it's very powerful
mashallah
you know and just you know it's
inspiring to see you guys do this
mashallah
uh you know especially uh brother um you
know um
is it how did you say name bro i'm sorry
i i'm like
you know you've been muslim for almost a
year right
now alhamdulillah just to see you
mashallah you know
not only try to better yourself but just
to help others
you know see that concern for people and
doing this you know so soon after
you became muslim is inspiring mashallah
man it's really inspiring may allah
bless you and increase you
i mean i mean i mean bro much respect
for
her yeah guys if you made it this far
smash that like button
share the video with someone that you
think might need it may allah bless you
all salaam alaikum
first and foremost the prophet salallahu
he said that
basically when a group of companies came
to him and asked you know we're dealing
with these horrible
doubts you know these doubts that if we
believe them they would lead to kufur
horrible doubts and the prophet
salallahu he said that this is good news
this is good news and obviously it's
very it sounds
upsy moronic how is you know big doubts
in faith
good news in the process he said it's a
sign of high iman
and think about it if you have
catastrophic
life-changing doubts about your religion
it can't be anything other than a sign
that you have
high faith because you don't wake up in
the morning
and become worried that unicorns don't
exist
because you never believed in unicorns
in the first place so the fact that
these
doubts are worrying you is a sign that
you have high iman
that you actually believe in islam
[Music]
[Music]
um